this this is why I love the show
let them eat pie I am late with this
review I was having technical issues and
then I had a really packed weekend so I
did not get this out in the time that I
wanted and really annoyed cuz all this
was a really good episode I mean this is
so much about what I love about Gotham
about the characters about the story
tell them about all of it so yeah that's
your that's your spoiler free stuff I am
gonna get into spoilers so be aware I
love what they've done with Professor
Pig for a number of reasons first of all
I just think it's a really executed arc
I think he's a compelling and fun
villain I think the way he's going about
things has been really fun to watch it's
been really interesting watch how other
wheaton characters have reacted to him
and not just the cops to see him in the
room with penguin that was really good
watch the two of them just kind of
surprise each other a little all great
stuff I love that they did this with a
lesser known villain as opposed to going
for one of the other big names that they
haven't touched yet that was a nice
change of pace as much as I I don't have
the issue with Gotham that a lot of
people have like ah there you can't have
these bills before Batman like I'm Way
over that I said I also don't want them
to burn through too many of the big name
Batman villains so taking professor Pig
and really making something very
memorable out of them that is great and
that's and that's something that I'm
really enjoying the heck out they've
done that with a number of characters I
think they've done it now best with him
I think Victor Zsasz is another one
picture says is fairly memorable from
the comics but I've latched on to him on
this show way more than anything else so
I loved what they did with the character
I love the character that they chose to
do it with I'm really liking where
they're going with penguin now I was a
little bit nervous a couple of episodes
leading into this cuz it felt like they
were doing the whole oh people are
emotionally manipulating penguin again
thing which has been done a couple of
times and was done very well last season
with the whole thing between him and
Edie went down this time Penguin has not
forgotten what's going on and it he's
room
this episode especially has reminded us
that even though he is very much ruled
by his emotions he is still paying
attention he is clever you can't
underestimate him which the people
around him clearly are they think
they've got him figured out they're like
well he's a problem but we know how he
works he can be unpredictable and that
in this episode has really good and it's
important to keeping penguin relevant
which I think I'm not sure he was
actually in danger of becoming
irrelevant but I was afraid that it was
gonna start to become one of those
characters who was around because he's
always been around and he wasn't
actually doing anything massively
relevant anymore this episode reaffirms
his not only importance to the universe
but that he is an impact and a wild card
in many ways as far as all this goes I'm
surprisingly really liking what's going
on with Bruce right now especially
relation between Bruce and Alfred
because I Bruce has been up and down for
me over the course of this show
sometimes he hasn't worked for me
sometimes he's worked quite well he's
gone and he's gone back and forth
repeatedly and I've said before I didn't
really care for the Rachel Ghul arc in
general I am liking how it's playing out
right now with Bruce I like that we're
seeing the impact of it I like that
Alfred is trying to do this connection
and I feel that the relationship between
the two and the degree to which Bruce is
resisting it
makes sense for the character and for an
overall arc especially since he has
gotten some degree this version of Bruce
has gotten some degree of closure over
his parents death that our normal Bruce
Wayne has never gotten and so I think
it's important that since he's gotten
that that he is damaged by the process
with which he got his quote/unquote
revenge cuz oftentimes sort of the the
way Batman works is that he doesn't ever
get closure on his parents death and
that's a big part of what drives him to
be Batman this young this won't happen
to anyone else
I couldn't get proper resolution on my
damage so I'm gonna funnel that into
this other thing here they're taking a
different tact which is that Bruce did
get resolution or at least he got what
he thought he wanted out of Rose
Ellucian relative to his parents death
but it didn't help it didn't make the
pain go away it didn't fill the void in
his life and so he's now gonna have to
fill that with something else
initially clearly with damaging stuff
and then eventually down the road with
being Batman and I I'd like this dip and
it very much mirrors what happened with
Gordon because Gordon came in to this
show as the white knight he was boring I
didn't care for him they hadn't go to a
darker place made a more interesting and
now they have him coming out the other
side of that trying to attain that that
initial ideal again knowing that he's
damaged but still saying this is a goal
worth striving for and I feel like
they're mirroring that in a lot of ways
with Bruce because we've seen him start
down the path of the the vigilante the
mask he was out at night and that that
was working for me but it almost did
seem a little bit like are we heading to
straight line to Batman I was like no
we're gonna detour into this damaged
area and then eventually he'll come back
up and reclaim that that thing that he
let go when he thought he didn't need it
or wasn't helping or what-have-you so
I'm loving all of that Sophia is still
she's she's not the strongest of the
elements that's at play in this
particular episode but she is working
well for me in the way that she is
affecting other characters for the most
part the Martine stuff I really like
that aspect basically with what it
brought out with penguin that he is
admitting to this connection with this
child but he's not stupid he he actually
hadn't thought at the same time I had
the thought cuz when he said you know a
mute spy I thought oh well he's gonna
try and use this kid to get to Sofia
it's gotta be a twist if he was really
using the kid to get to him but he
starts hugging this kid and he realizes
this is a possibility alright oh my oh
good on your Oswalt nice and again I'm
just liking what that dynamic is
bringing out a penguin it's helping
bringing him back to what I loved when
the characters really firing on all
cylinders and this this has just been a
real highlight highlight episode of this
season so far certainly I love this I
don't know what comes next because now
we've we've appeared to have for the
time close out the professor Pig story
so don't know what's next but man I love
this
so those are my thoughts on the latest
episode of Gotham what were your
thoughts on it whatever they were drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it don't forget to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
council of geeks give a listen to the
council of geeks podcast that's
available on Apple podcast as well as
stitcher radio I'm also one half of the
punch like a girl podcast that is a
presentation of the fire and water
podcast network fire and water
podcast.com there's links below for all
this stuff and until next time this
council is adjourned
[Applause]
[Applause]